l'étendue d'eau respire le calme et la
tranquillité
mais l'image est trompeuse car ces jours
ci de là tchad et les temps de tous les
dangers
ces soldats tchadiens le savent chaque
fois qu'il s'y aventurant patrouille
s'est lourdement armés car chaque
pirogue rencontrer chaque île habitée
chante autant en embuscade potentiel le
lac tchad ici qui est à la frontière
entre le tchad et le nigeria a toujours
d une zone très sensible mais la
sécurité ici vient d'être sérieusement
renforcée depuis les attaques répétées
de boko haram dans la région en janvier
dernier boko haram a attaqué la base
militaire nigériane de bagua sur les
berges du lac massacrant des centaines
d'habitants de la ville
pourchassant même jusqu'au tchad de
l'autre côté du lac les civils ayant fui
le carnage abakar mahamat à like honey
la menace ce soda tchadien a dû
repousser les attaques des jihadistes
pour moi les boko haram deux sont des
criminels des bandits qui profitent de
l'absence des forces de sécurité pour
s'en prendre aux populations est alors
bien dit-il lac a été déclaré tôt
militaires patrouillent et en permanence
par des soldats des quatre pays
riverains lynch adien contrôle des
embarcations rencontrer pour s'assurer
qu'ils ne transportent pas d'armes
ni de djihadistes il y trouve le plus
souvent des villageois apeurée est
excédé comme à bacau tous pêcheurs du
village de tags halle aux grains
pourquoi ram est un poison un gros
problème
depuis qu'il est là village notre région
on ne peut plus circuler et vendre notre
poisson mais tiago les îles sur le lac
abrite aujourd'hui des milliers de
déplacés du nigeria les soldats ont déjà
escorté bon nombre d'entre eux vers le
grand camp de réfugiés de dar es salaam
côté tchad mais beaucoup d'autres s'y
trouvent encore souvent prisonniers de
lac au calme trompeur
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
bagages ceux-là tchad et on retrouve
jean françois ce soir jean-françois
cette offensive contre boko haram a dure
depuis des mois le président sortant du
nigeria goodluck johnatan avait promis
de régler le problème avant les
élections mais dans les faits sont
plutôt les pays voisin du nigeria qui
font le travail sur le terrain
oui céline et ça soulève d'ailleurs pas
mal de questions parce que le nigeria
qui est en fait le pays le plus peuplé
d'afrique a en théorie en tout cas une
arme est beaucoup plus forte que celle
des pays voisins importants en six ans
faut bien le reconnaître l'armée
nigériane a pas réussi à accomplir grand
chose contre boko haram alors que des
pays qui sont en théorie beaucoup plus
modeste plus pauvres en tout cas comme
le tchad comme le niger eux ont réussi à
infliger de sérieux revers aux
islamistes de boko haram et ce sur le
territoire même du nigeria et ça je vous
dirais que ça commence à créer des
tensions sur place du président tchadien
idriss déby par exemple ne cache plus
son énervement il a même critiqué
publiquement le manque d'implication des
troupes nigérianes le manque de
coordination aussi qui a forcé en fait
les soldats tchadiens reprendre deux
fois défilé des mains de boko haram la
même ville parce que les soldats
nigérians qui devait se déployer sur
place entre temps ne l'ont pas fait on
parle de plus en plus et depuis
plusieurs mois de la crise
a sion d'une force multinationale pour
lutter contre boko haram qui pourrait
être placée sous l'égide des nations
unies ou plus probablement sur celle de
l'union africaine je vous dirais que ça
lorsque ça va se concrétiser lorsque
cette force là va être déployé sur le
terrain ça devrait aider à sécuriser un
petit peu la zone cela dit il faut bien
le reconnaître on est très très loin
d'une victoire totale contre boko haram
cette victoire totale qui avait promise
le président sortant nigérian goodluck
johnatan parce que boko haram adoptent
de plus en plus sur le terrain des
tactiques de guérilla de guerres
asymétriques comme d'ailleurs les
talibans en afghanistan
et ça on le sait pour une armée
régulière ça en fait un ennemi
extrêmement difficile à combattre
merci beaucoup jean françois nous emplir
voir et un rappel sur boko haram le
groupe armé islamiste est né en 2002
dans l'état de borno dans le nord-est du
nigeria
ces exactions se sont détendus
principalement dans les états de yobe et
de gambe et à la frontière du tchad
boko haram veut instaurer un état
islamique rejetant toute éducation
occidentale
il s'est autoproclamé déclaré khalifa en
il ya quelques semaines il a prêté
allégeance aux groupes armés et thaïs
lamic ses actions militaires ont
commencé en 2009 et en fait depuis
quelques treize mille morts on se
souviendra de l'enlèvement des 237
lycéenne l'an dernier on ne sait
toujours pas ce qu'il est advenu de la
grande majorité d'entre elles